transposing America that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
as we just discussed killer Audrey Hale
was living in a sick fantasy world
one that was affirmed and celebrated by
modern culture
the fraudulent construct the boys can
become girls and girls can become boys
in her Twisted mind her mortal enemies
are those who do not affirm her
imaginary identity in this case her old
Christian School and her family
and thus she goes and blows away six
innocent people
including three small children
now the knee-jerk political response
very predictable it's to blame the gun
culture urge that AR-15s be banned
but this avoids the undeniable truth
that the left has created a world that
has our young people on a collision
course with reality
one that's aligned against the
judeo-christian tradition at odds with
basic Common Sense even basic human
biology
in our educational our corporate and our
political leaders are creating
generation l
for lost and lonely and looking looking
for meaning and love in all the wrong
places
now as is typical the left rushes to
deflect blame for where their horrid
policies and anti-values have taken us
what I will say to republicans in
Congress is what are you going to say to
these parents obviously they must not
believe in an afterlife because they
know the consequences of what they are
doing pronouns do not kill children
right people with guns kill children and
it's going to be a distraction in our
coverage
you know what's not a distraction the
fact that more young people today are
reporting mental illness Suicidal
Thoughts depression
they're reporting more of this than ever
before
so they're more connected with the
internet and all their devices yet
they're less connected than ever before
why is that
well social media is a black hole
encouraging bullying buffoonery
sexualization of young people a total
time suck and of course encouraging body
image disorders
most Americans are just waking up now to
the grip it has on our kids
we don't want our children to turn out
as entitled cynics or despondent
slackers
that means it's incumbent upon each of
us to teach them that they have inherent
worth as human beings that God has a
special path for them all of them and
that yes they're blessed to live in our
country which has been founded on
Liberty that there's virtue and hard
work and patriotism
so tonight I'm asking what happened to
that America
a shocking new poll in the Wall Street
Journal shows a steep decline in our
patriotism
back in 1998 70 percent of Americans
said it was very important to them the
idea of patriotism today that support
has nosedived to only 38 percent almost
halved
the most startling fact is the collapse
in Democrats patriotism
now why has this happened
Democrats used to Value patriotism FDR
JFK and yes Bill Clinton he sounded
pretty patriotic in his day
the demands of our time are great
and they are different let us build our
Bridge a bridge wide enough and strong
enough for every American to cross over
to a blessed land
of new promise
it's very hopeful well the real problem
started of course with the Obamas early
on in his career Barack Obama was
hopeful he sounded hopeful in 2004
during that famous speech that launched
his career he said famously there are no
red States or blue states that we are
the United States
but then he became more and more
negative as time went on America's shown
arrogance
and been dismissive
even derisive the United States is still
working through some of our own darker
periods in our history people in this
country are ready for change
and and and hungry for a different kind
of politics for the first time in my
adult life I am proud of my country
but Trump turned that around didn't they
he leaned into patriotism to build a new
movement of dedicated Americans who were
tired of the government subverting our
national interest we'll rekindle New
Faith in our values
new pride in our history
and a new spirit of unity that can only
be realized through love for our great
country
well Democrats didn't care how much they
hurt the country or hurt our national
pride they had a weaponized FBI they had
a summer of riots cities burned people
beaten and killed statues and monuments
torn down celebrated them being tore
down talibanesque
they sold the Relentless message that
America is systemically racist and evil
it's still being sold
it's a lie and it's being sold every day
by this Administration all to energize
their base to turn out against Trump
back in 2020 and now perhaps in 2024
and they still haven't stopped using
government prosecutors to harass
president Trump to this very day to jail
non-violent January 6 protesters and
even to harass journalists who are
exposing their ongoing fraud like Matt
taibi
I'm sure it was just a coincidence that
IRS agents showed up at his house
well Democrats don't really care though
about the consequences of swinging this
wrecking ball as long as they win in
2024.
they prefer Americans put their trust in
global institutions anyway
they've already convinced the rest of
the world that we're corrupt and evil
and now they're finding a more receptive
audience here at home
and who could ever ever imagine the
entertainment Community today producing
a film that puts China in a bad light
can you imagine it I can't where's that
documentary about the Hong Kong Freedom
protesters or a real film about Mao's
Great Leap Forward in the millions upon
Millions he killed how about the plight
of the uyghurs
of course not they're going to do any of
that
but Hollywood loves putting America down
well except maybe for Maverick Top Gun
and even in that movie remember it was
an amorphous enemy that wouldn't offend
anyone out there in the movie-going
audience
the target
is an unsanctioned uranium enrichment
Plant built in violation of a
multilateral NATO treaty the uranium
produced there represents a direct
threat to our allies in the region
there where's there
well the repercussions
the devouring atriotism is enormous
America is never going to improve unless
more of us love America enough to
sacrifice for America and help figure
out how to make it a better place
we need voters who are so invested in
Saving this country that they actually
demand better leaders next time
and we need to insist on holding all of
our elected officials in both parties
accountable
Biden cannot I don't care what you're
saying or what you believe tonight Biden
cannot be the best we can do in 2024.
he's been outmaneuvered and outsmarted
at every turn on the world stage he's
wrecked our economy and is now opening
the door to China's becoming the
strongest power in the world
we're expanding legal Pathways for
migration to seek safety and
humanitarian humanitarian basis so today
I applaud China for stepping assuming I
applaud Canada
one of those sea countries
now the left is spreading vicious lies
about America and our schools this is
very poisonous of course sadly the
Republican Party in the Republican party
people are also losing faith as well
they see how bad the situation really is
awoke military a hostile business
Community
anti-American schools where again
everyone's taught that the country is
systemically racist
so people on the right are also becoming
discouraged
so at some point if enough conservatives
think that every institution of the
government and the culture is aligned
against them
it's even going to be difficult to get
them to sacrifice and wave the flag
so let me say this tonight
Republicans must avoid the pessimism
trap as well
if they're convinced that voting doesn't
matter because the other side will cheat
anyway
then they don't show up to vote uh
how are you going to fix this mess that
we're in
but the stakes are too important to let
that happen
we are indeed at a Tipping Point I know
a lot of people say that but we're at it
we have no time to argue about the
obvious or deny basic facts or pretend
we're living in a fantasy world where
you know one sex can become another sex
we can't allow charlatans to divide us
hard work Family Faith and patriotism is
what will save us they always have and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else